le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais la réunion la
croissance économique et social a été
fulgurant en seulement quelques
décennies des changements de valeurs et
de repères importants ont pu être
modifié ou égratigner les priorités ont
changé au fil des générations
cette métamorphose a néanmoins offert à
la réunion une situation économique
performant ces dernières années mais
l'heure est à la remise en question car
la crise économique est d'actualité
beaucoup de choses deviennent plus
compliquées
une fatalité qui affecte le moral des
réunionnais l'engagement personnel et
collectif en ait diminué
pourtant qu'elles soient sportives
économiques individuelle ou collective
il y a beaucoup de réussite à la réunion
des exemples qui démontrent que malgré
une époque difficile
les réunionnais sont formidables la
situation géographique de la réunion
nous offre des avantages comme la
qualité de notre climat
mais dans certains cas cet éloignement
peut être un frein à nos ambitions
il faut donc redoubler d'efforts pour
aller au bout de ses rêves se battre
encore plus fort et surtout garder
l'espoir et la confiance en soi
les difficultés de notre contexte social
et économique peuvent parfois prendre le
dessus
nous empêcher de rêver ou de garder
toutes nos forces pourtant certaines
valeurs comme la combativité le respect
il estime de soi bat très fort dans le
coeur de certains réunionnais lucie
ignace en est le parfait exemple
à seulement 19 ans elle a remporté le
titre de championne du monde de karaté
dans les sports de combat elle est la
seule avec mike tyson à avoir gagné ce
titre aussi jeune lucie santana la
réunion loin du reste de l'équipe de
france un choix qu'elle assume et qui ne
l'empêchent pas de continuer de garder
et d'améliorer son niveau mais l'uci
doit redoubler d'efforts pour compenser
l'éloignement pour elle c'est une fierté
de continuer de s'entraîner à la réunion
malgré les difficultés sociales et de
représenter son île dans les
compétitions une conviction qu'elle
souhaite communiquer aux jeunes futurs
champions de leur dire qu'il faut se
fixer des objectifs et il faut prendre
exemple sur les plus grands sur les plus
les plus titrés en guillemets pour les
sportifs et se dire aussi que moi je
peux y arriver comme moi je me suis dit
je regardais des grands sportifs
auparavant c'est vrai qu'on n'y croit
pas vraiment mais quand on se met un
objectif en tête on fait tout pour y
arriver et je veux leur dire qu'il faut
vraiment croire en leurs rêves et
et qui peuvent y arriver vous avez
agnone son formidable ça veut dire que
malgré la distance par rapport à la
france pour moi personnellement je crois
de l'équipe de france s'entraîne
ensemble moi je suis la seule à
m'entraîner ici et donc je trouve ça
peut enfin il faut que je travaille deux
fois plus que pour pouvoir réussir et
aussi à voir en gros niveau garder mon
niveau donc du coup pour moi être
formidable ça veut dire se donner les
moyens quoi qu'il en soit malgré la
distance malgré l'éloignement et comme
j'étais heureuse et toujours y croire
c'est un honneur pour moi de participer
à cet agenda avec tous les sportifs
réunionnais qui aime et qui représente
le rythme est ce aussi pour montrer
qu'avec des efforts du travail du
courage on peut y arriver et on peut
atteindre ses objectifs et ses rêves
la réunion est une terre aux multiples
talents dont les meilleurs ambassadeurs
sont deux sportifs pays qui depuis des
décennies font autant rêver que vibrer
les coeurs des supporters que nous
sommes malgré l'éloignement de la
métropole et des grands centres
d'entraînement malgré les obstacles qui
ont pu se dresser devant eux ils n'ont
jamais baissé les bras
au contraire ils se sont battus ont
gravi une à une les marches du succès
pour atteindre les sommets et faire
rayonner leur île au plus haut niveau
que ce soit en sport individuel ou
collectif
leur exploit personnel sont immenses
leurs histoires sont magiques
au point que les superlatifs peuvent
nous manquer quand nous voyons leur
palmarès
les réunionnais sont formidables et ça
n'est pas qu'un slogan
il ya aujourd'hui des potentialités
existantes la jeunesse tirer
si des adultes qui innovent croient en
leur pays et font des choses
extraordinaires que ce soit sur le plan
professionnel et même personnel ils sont
pas souvent mis en lumière il via avec
la crise une certaine morosité à la
réunion les jeunes qui n'ont pas
d'emploi par exemple s'exprime sûrement
à travers des questionnements de doutes
de crainte et et nous voulons cette
année montré que les réunionnais ils
sont formidables comme ils l'ont été
avant nous et nous allons décliner cette
thématique dans toutes les sphères de la
vie publique au conseil général pour
mettre en place avec des parrains mais
aussi des jeunes ceux qui sont déjà dans
l'activité reconnu en pleine lumière
un maillage pour préparer la venue
alumine de la réunion la réunion
nouvelle le conseil général a souhaité
rendre hommage et mettre en valeur
celles et ceux qui à force de courage de
persévérance et de détermination sont
devenus les porte drapeaux de la réunion
de l'excellence des modèles de réussite
des exemples à suivre pour bon nombre
d'entre nous que ce soit dans le sport
dans les collectivités les entreprises
et dans bien d'autres domaines encore
certains continueront de nous prouver
qu'il ne faut pas se laisser envahir par
la morosité et continuer de se donner
les moyens d'atteindre ses rêves il faut
se prouver à soi-même et au reste du
monde que les réunions
son formidable le conseil général de la
réunion vous a présenté lien social le
conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais